since around 1750 we've been living in a
highly distinctive era in the history of
love that we can call Romanticism
romanticism emerged as an ideology in
Europe in the mid 18th century in the
minds of poets artists and philosophers
and it's now conquered the world
no single relationship ever follows the
romantic template exactly but its broad
outlines are frequently present
nevertheless and can be summed up as
follows
romanticism is deeply hopeful about
marriage
romanticism took marriage hitherto seen
as a practical and emotionally temperate
Union and fused it together with a
passionate love story to create a unique
proposition the lifelong passionate love
marriage along the way
romanticism United love and sex
previously people had imagined that they
could have sex with characters they
didn't love and that they could love
someone without having extraordinary sex
with them
romanticism elevated sex to the supreme
expression of love frequent mutually
satisfying sex became the bellwether of
the health of any relationship without
necessarily meaning to romanticism made
infrequent sex and adultery into
catastrophes romanticism proposed the
true love must mean an end to all
loneliness the right partner must it
promised understand us entirely possibly
without needing even to speak to us they
would ensure it our souls romantics put
a special premium on the idea that our
partner might understand us without
needing to say anything
romanticism believed that choosing a
partner should be about letting oneself
be guided by feelings rather than
practical considerations you know you're
in love because you have a special
feeling
romanticism has manifested a powerful
disdain for practicalities and money it
feels cold
or as we say unromantic to say you know
you're with the right person because the
two of you make an excellent financial
fit or because you gel over things like
bathroom etiquette and attitudes to
punctuality romanticism believes that
true love is synonymous with accepting
everything about someone the idea that
one's partner
or oneself may need to change is taken
to be a sign that the relationship is on
the rocks you're going to have to change
is a last-ditch threat this template of
love is a historical creation it's a
hugely beautiful and often enjoyable one
but we can stay boldly romanticism has
been a disaster for relationships it's
an intellectual and spiritual movement
which has had a devastating impact on
the ability of ordinary people to lead
successful emotional lives the salvation
of love lies in overcoming a succession
of errors within romanticism these are
some of the myths of Romanticism
that we should meet a person of
extraordinary inner and outer beauty and
immediately feel a special attraction to
them and they to us we should have
highly satisfying sex not only at the
start but forever we should never be
attracted to anyone else we should
understand one another intuitively we
don't need an education in love we may
need to train to become a pilot or brain
surgeon but not a lover we'll pick that
up along the way by following our
feelings we should have no secrets and
spend constant time together work won't
get in the way we should raise a family
without any loss of sexual or emotional
intensity our lover must be our soul
mate best friend co-parent Co chauffeur
accountant household manager and
spiritual guide if we question the
assumptions of the romantic view of love
it's not in order to destroy love but to
save it we need to piece together a post
romantic theory of couples because in
order to make a relationship last we
have to be disloyal to the romantic
emotions that get us into it in the
first place we need to replace the
romantic template with a psychologically
mature vision of love we might call
classical and which encourages in us a
range of unfamiliar but hopefully
effective attitudes for example that
it's normal that love and sex may not
always belong together that discussing
money early on upfront in a serious way
is not a betrayal of love but realizing
that we're rather flawed and our partner
is too is a huge benefit to a couple
because it increases the amount of
tolerance and generosity and circulation
that we will never find everything in
one
person nor they in us not because of
some unique floor but because that's
just the way human nature is that we
need to make immense and often rather
artificial sounding efforts to
understand one another that intuition
can't get us where we need to go and
that's spending two hours discussing
where the bathroom towels should be hung
up or can be left on the floor is
neither trivial nor unserious there is a
special dignity around issues of laundry
and time keeping all these attitudes and
more belong to a new more hopeful post
romantic future for love
you